I think CBS is making a mistake because
I think they're stifling the creativity
of fans who love Star Trek fans don't
want to be on the outside anymore we've
moved to a new level of intimacy and
collaboration and connectedness we want
to be inside the world that's what
virtual reality is we want to be in it
space the final frontier these are the
voyages of the Starship Enterprise
since its launch in 1966 Star Trek has
inspired intense devotion from
generations of fans with five television
series spanning 50 years and a sixth set
to launch in 2017 and this month's
release of Star Trek Beyond will mark
the franchise's thirteenth feature film
and that is just the official Star Trek
product sesor stands hard to say command
room almost the very beginning
Star Trek inspired creativity amongst
the fans Star Trek creator Gene
Roddenberry expressed deep gratitude for
the fans and encouraged their work
Gene Roddenberry wrote a foreword to
Star Trek new voyages where he said you
know thank goodness for the fans and the
fans were doing that you know through
fanzines through artwork and then they
started doing it with fan films
the first really hardcore Star Trek fan
film was 1973 called Paragons Paragon
and there was a carpet layer from
Michigan who spent 2,000 dollars of his
own money to make a bridge set in 1985
fan filmmaker in Los Angeles actually
got George Takei to play Sulu in his fan
film called Yorktown I'd say the true
birth of the modern fan film happened in
2000 when Star Trek hidden frontier they
created seven seasons they filmed in
front of a green screen and they chroma
keyed in images of you know the bridge
and engineering whatever and then in
2004 James Cawley in upstate New York
spent about a hundred two hundred fifty
thousand dollars of his own money
recreating the original bridge
inch-by-inch recreation and he created
something called Star Trek new voyages
that fancy ship to yours can get off the
mat it's time we finished this thing off
aye aye captain helm firing position so
after new voyages there was this amazing
proliferation of Star Trek fan films
that started there was starship extras
they were starship Farragut a project
Potemkin Star Trek of gods and men
starred amongst other people walter
Koenig playing check I'm Nichelle
Nichols playing or Hurra
eventually you had huge productions like
Star Trek renegades where it was a
90-minute movie they had a Westwood
theater premiere the fan films were just
getting bigger and bigger and bigger all
fan films share one thing and it's this
amazing passion for the subject matter
Alec Peters is the head of Axanar
productions and represents the latest
iteration of the Star Trek fan film one
that the studio suddenly looks a lot
less like harmless fandom and more like
competition a professionally shot
produced and acted short film called
prelude to Axanar
the greatest challenge slain before us
is
to do what must be done without undoing
the dream with the Federation the video
has 2.5 million views on YouTube
147 Film Festival Awards all over the
world it's probably the most successful
Star Trek fan film of all time fans were
so impressed with prelude to Axanar that
they donated more than four hundred
thousand dollars towards the team's
Kickstarter campaign to expand it into a
feature film and then former Trek cast
member and social media star George
Takei posted his support on his
massively popular Facebook page
George blasted out there and in 24 hours
we raised another two hundred and twenty
thousand dollars it was like one of
those commercials where you see the
odometer just start good wrong the
accent our team even landed Richard
Hatch not a trek cast member but the
captain on another beloved sci-fi series
Battlestar Galactica it was it feel like
being part of the Star Trek universe
after starring in both versions of
Battlestar Galactica absolutely amazing
I love Star Trek and being able to play
such a deep profound character as
general Karn absolutely astounding for
me with more than 1 million dollars in
the bank for Axanar between its
Kickstarter and IndieGoGo campaigns
Peters and his crew began construction
on a full-fledged set and soundstage
meanwhile CBS and paramount sprung into
action I wake up in the morning I opened
my computer I look at Facebook and I see
this article on Hollywood Reporter and
it says CBS and paramount sue Star Trek
fan film then I realize oh that's
probably us CBS had started a war the
lawsuit alleged copyright infringement
and demanded Axanar put an immediate
stop to production they also faced fines
of up to $150,000 per violation CBS
declined to participate in this video
but referred us to an interview that
their senior vice-president of licensing
gave to the official Star Trek podcast
the production started spiraling larger
and a larger there's something of an
arms race about how many Hollywood names
could be attached how many people that
have previously worked on track how many
famous actors could you involve and
that's not really in the spirit of fan
fiction there's a lot of fans who are
gifted professionals and I say
professionals they have professional
skills technology
has advanced way beyond what we're used
to now there's the democratization of
filmmaking and then you have
crowdfunding and the studio's don't know
how to react to it like big corporations
they react by rejecting it rather than
figuring out how to embrace it I don't
think any of this is happening in a
vacuum so I think along with Alec Peters
creating a studio and with racks not
raising a million dollars there was also
the 50th anniversary there was the new
movie coming out there was the new TV
series coming out there was probably a
desire by the studio let's concentrate
on our Star Trek and not let fans have
their Star Trek for a bit people have
gotten used to full like 1960's length
episodes of you know 50 minutes 50
minutes plus 90 minute feature films but
that's that's what we do but Peters
believes that accent are is protected by
a legal concept known as fair use there
are certain types of speech that should
be protected and you should be able to
use a certain amount of copyrighted
works in order to accomplish things like
commentary and critique Dean cheeley is
a copyright attorney at the Donaldson
and Calif firm they represented the
documentary room 237 which consists
almost entirely of footage from Stanley
Kubrick's The Shining but qualified as
fair use because various interview
subjects give a constant running
commentary about the secret messages
they believe are embedded in the film
the firm also represented escape from
tomorrow a movie shot on site at
Disney's the Magic Kingdom without
permission from Disney and they notched
a landmark fair use case when they
defeated Yoko Ono the wife of late
Beatles star John Lennon in the
documentary expelled narrated by Ben
Stein they used a snippet from John
Lennon's Imagine underneath archival
footage of brutal communist and fascist
regimes as a form of ironic commentary
about anti religious movements these
examples all comment upon the
copyrighted content that utilize but the
acts in our case is not so
straightforward as Chile we're often
asked the question and whether or not
fan films are covered by fair use if
it's using characters and plot lines and
copyrighted elements to simply create a
new original story
in this essence of prequel it's unlikely
that that would be a fair use while
legally I think that CBS may actually
have a legitimate claim on its hands I
don't think it's in their best interest
to pursue it you don't want to police
this type of fanzine to such extent that
you're really disenfranchising your your
audience fan films should be allowed
because they do nothing but promote the
product they can bring us maybe stories
that the studios aren't interested in
doing exploring characters that the
studio's don't really put a lot of
energy on and in a sense flesh out the
world and build even more interest so
that when the movies and the studio's
come out it actually generates more
money more fan interest and the fan
community is enlarged as a result of
these really really quality fan films in
fact years ago hatch spent his own money
to produce a sort of fan made remake of
Battlestar Galactica despite being told
by the studio that there wasn't enough
interest we finally arrived at Comic Con
in 2001 we had a packed room and we had
these crazy wild fans from all
generations in there and we played it
and it was the most quiet pin dropping
moment I've ever had in my life at the
end of it and then we got this explosion
of clapping and screaming and yelling I
thought oh my god he believes that the
reaction to his fan film proved to
Universal that there was an appetite for
more Battlestar and helped me to the
2004 reboot that ran for four seasons
spawned a spin-off and now is being
developed into a feature film it kind of
shows what you can do as with that
passion of a fan and I didn't know
anything about producing didn't know
anything about drink didn't know
anything about any of those things back
at that time but I I learned the hard
way
after Star Trek directors JJ Abrams and
Justin Lin both expressed public support
of Axanar CBS and paramount released a
set of fan film guidelines some of the
guidelines add involving disclaimer xand
policing the way filmmakers can title
their movies but the ones that most
rankled the fans include a time limit of
15 minutes a fund-raising limit of
$50,000 and a prohibition on including
former Star Trek cast and crew or any
other professionals half of them
have a problem with ones I do have a
problem with the ones that most fans
have a problem with we have a big
problem it seems to me that like they
went through every fan film and
specifically tried to come up with
guidelines that would eliminate that fan
film from from happening the lawsuit is
still pending and production attacks in
our studios is temporarily ground to a
halt but Peters and his team believe
that the momentum of technology and
history is on their side and that
resistance to change is futile after all
in the wise words of Spock change is the
essential process of all existence and
that nobody's gonna be able to slow that
down just like they can't slow down
globalization they can't slow down that
the audience is hungry for more
connection it's not just us we're
fighting for at this point it's fan
films and artists in general then law
students today are having to watch
butters saying what what in the butt in
their classrooms I hope that that's the
legacy of this case
this disconnect between the public's
view of copyright and fair use and on
what should and should not be prosecuted
versus the copyright Maximus view of the
law is our generations prohibition
[Music]